[Applause]
that's going to catch on that's going to
be huge i like that i love forest how
are you foreskins are terrific by the
way i've seen i never saw one before one
time i saw one in a locker room and i i
stared at it forever i swear to god i
never saw one like and there was a kid
his name was frenchy and uh yeah and he
had he had one yeah anybody got one
anybody got a foreskin all right sorry
conan it's depressing uh nobody does it
anymore man
it's crazy
uh now first of all this is nice because
i was thinking about this today this is
a little bit of a homecoming for you
because now many people know this yes a
lot of people think you're you know
you're from new hampshire but you
actually you're you're from brooklyn if
you're going to be perfectly honest with
that right yeah i mean i was i lived in
brooklyn i was a little kid how little
uh up to i i moved to new hampshire when
i was five okay so i uh so but the
brooklyn things you know you're kind of
there's something about the brooklyn
thing that always felt cool when you're
a little kid like hey i'm from brooklyn
you know yeah so uh and when i moved to
new hampshire i kept that going you know
like i was brooklyn all the time i was
always acting like i knew brooklyn so
good hey
all the other kids thought i was cool
like a real brooklyn thug until like a
real guy from brooklyn would show up and
they'd be like hey jimmy yeah sandler's
from uh brooklyn the guy would come over
yeah
where are you from what neighborhood uh
main street
yeah what school
italian ice
we got a fake here oh yeah why don't you
go choke on a la guardia
and then the beating would ensue yeah
now you have if you have a strong
connection to to new york uh yes i would
sometimes uh with new hampshire can go
either way
with the baseball loyalties but you're a
yankee guy everybody else is from my
name yeah i like the youngsters
yankees it's tough to be a yankee fan
especially uh where i grew up they hated
that but anywhere in the country a lot
of people hate the yankees for some
reason you know because they
they say something buying buying their
team and all they get mad at all that
but uh i uh so i don't like it and yell
that's that's so i i only wear the
yankee hat in in new york if when i'm
outside in new york i wear just a big
pink top hat
a pink top turns out if that happens to
be the team hat for the fire island
magicians so
and and people don't like that meter so
i catch beatings for that too
now i understand congratulations are in
order is this true your nephew just
graduated from harvard no he is a smart
boy and he got in there my f you know
it's a big honor for our family that
this kid tyler was a nice boy and he
graduated uh harvard and i i i would
always feel like because i'm movie star
mcgee in the house everyone's like hey
movie star he's adam's unbelievable but
this kid like used his brain
accomplish something
but
that's nice what a nice loving family
environment yeah yeah exactly all right
movies tonight this kid's got a brain
what have you done lately i know i know
he tried to put a hurt on me by being at
harvard but when i went to the harvard
graduation december they would like out
of nowhere gave me an honorary degree
so like
all these he's waiting to get his
diploma and then i go before we give out
the diplomas an honorary degree to
harvard adam sandler and i i was like
what and then i i walked and i passed
and i go got your
[Applause]
felt good yeah it sounds like the price
is right and i want me another degree
all right